je veux d'abord vous exprimé les
remerciements et la reconnaissance de
nos concitoyens de calais et d'ailleurs
pour le travail que vous effectuez jour
après jour nuit après nuit travail
remarquable mais peu connu parfois
décrié souvent caricaturé les
approximations sur votre action à calais
parfois les mensonges souvent les
manipulations ne vis au final qu'un seul
but mettre à mal la politique mise en
oeuvre par le gouvernement
il faut donc faire oeuvre de pédagogie
décrire méthodiquement je le ferai dans
le détail
vos missions et dans quelles conditions
vous les effectuer je veux le dire ici
très clairement la france est une
république il ya un président de la
république il ya un premier ministre qui
conduit l'action du gouvernement et un
ministre en charge de l'intérieur
il a auprès de lui des préfets la
politique elle est une elle est
expliquée
le gouvernement en est responsable
devant le parlement
et il en répond chaque jour où il est
interrogé et dans la république
les fonctionnaires applique la politique
du gouvernement et c'est le cas chaque
jour alors que ceux qui ont quelque
chose à reprocher au gouvernement
s'attaque à sa politique mais qu'il ne
s'attaque pas à ses fonctionnaires
qu'ils ne disent pas des contre-vérités
sur ses fonctionnaires et je m'étonne
que des commentateurs que des dirigeants
d'organisations diverses et variées qui
parfois d'ailleurs honte à s'exprimer
sur la fonction publique on a représenté
des fonctionnaires se permettent
d'écrire ce qu'ils ont pu écrire sur le
quotidien de notre fonction publique
dans la république française
les fonctionnaires quel qu'il soit ne se
comporte pas tel qu'il le dise